hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and today
we're looking at episodes 118 and 119 of
hunter hunter and becoming
super saiyans because we're doing a
crossover with quinoa
episode 118 where has the time gone
there's a great deal of
misunderstandings happening this episode
and they're underscored by the moronic
behavior of two of the people who are
supposed to be protecting the world but
who have decided that their pride
is more important than the world which
again i kind of think should have got
them both killed the amount of time we
spent on knuckles thoughts lured us into
that sense of finality and of course
they were absolutely reminiscent of
leo's thoughts a few episodes ago and so
i was drawn into it naturally enraged
further to find that none of what he was
doing was worth it even to him when he
did it and actually
my complaints last episode that he would
learn nothing from it may well bear out
and so i'm doubly enraged
not quite as angry as you pee when he
decides to explode but you know pretty
angry
so we have youpi pulling the ultimate
switcheroo on knuckle who fell into it
immediately because he's full of his
revenge and idiocy i guess and his pride
stops him from considering that maybe up
has another way of using the power
or perhaps that maybe he's an
intelligent and competent creature and
often that's the way with pride right we
forget that the other creature might
have a sense of competence or that
they might just be competent except we
don't generally decide to kill them when
they're obviously stronger and
probably smarter it concerns me that
they've all used poor chameleon to get
things done but now he's picking up on
it or at least you pee up is picking up
on it chameleon is
i mean chameleon's fine with being used
but now he's now up
he's picking up on it and for
chameleon's sake i hope that kilowatt
does manage to take up down
it's also for my sake because no one
else wears a tracksuit like that
chameleon does
it's a really interesting shift from the
beginning of the arc to now because
on the whole i don't care about the good
guys and kind of feel like they deserve
to lose
other than kilwa who i want always to
win because he's my sweet little murder
baby back at the beginning of the arc i
wondered both who the protagonists were
and who we were supposed to see as the
protagonist because they're
sort of two different things
realistically back then maybe i should
have made a decision because now i feel
like i'm in a place where of those i've
seen i
only want pito and kilwa to win and i
feel as though if it were left to them
they
would likely win it's possible they they
will win
by win i mean get what they want but
still yupi i'm starting to feel endeared
to because he's developing as a
character and that's something i
personally appreciate in people and
entities
of which youpi is one of them gone has
decided to remain who he is
knuckle and shoot have not only decided
to remain who they are but are willing
to bet the world
and their own lives on them being who
they are kiwa is that self-sacrificing
alien assassin we all know and love who
like alf want to live in their own life
but largely make everyone else's better
in the meantime he doesn't seem to have
internal goals just internal conflict
and it's interesting to see someone
without any particular intention
take on the intentions and desires of
others as his own
with such an intensity i'd love to see
killua decide on what he wants his life
to be because ultimately
i don't think anyone could stop him or
at least once he'd learned to hold the
power for
you know more than more than the amount
of time he did that's the next episode
though
returning to the episode at hand poof is
on his way
out of smokey jail which sort of feels
like a cop-out given how powerful
morel's abilities have been in the past
i guess it's not that they don't make
sense but that it doesn't feel as
narratively interesting as two rather
talkative and intuitive characters
actually interacting further it feels
like a bit of a waste of both of their
abilities and
yes sure it's what's needed right now
for knuckle and shoot to be morons and
forgone to become a monster and for
kilowatt to be intensely sulky but
ultimately it feels like we held up
these characters and built up tension in
this part of the story to deliberately
leak it out slowly and
painfully it's not that i don't care
what happens to them but i
don't care what happens to them said
another way because that doesn't make
any sense
i care about the characters i think
they're great and i they really both
give off a
bodyguard jeeves kind of vibe that's
fascinating to see interact
but because the whole point is that
they're not interacting and
that all we're learning is that they
respect each other i'm not sure why we
keep coming back to them to continue to
learn exactly that same thing
meanwhile ikalgo's doing his thing and
it's great that we're seeing what he's
up to his tensions and fears and i think
i've just realized what it is
oh i've realized what it is that i'm
feeling ambivalent
i've realized what it is i'm feeling
ambivalent about although i know liam
won't be ambivalent about putting this
into the recording everything feels
rote not everything but some of it
because the main story isn't in these
locations but we still need to know
about them for whatever it is that's
going to come later tagashi's belaboring
the point to
inform us of what's happening ikalgo
looking for people and freaking out is
wonderful but it lacks the tension and
tightness of the rest of the episode the
slowness of the story to get it across
is necessary but not the duration i feel
like the whole icalgo storyline could
have been tightened up particularly the
information given in this episode and
when we lean on the narrator to tell us
things i kind of get annoyed that the
narrator didn't just tell us all of it
in
less words so we could skip to the
action which might feel like the
opposite of what i've said in the past
but the major difference between this
and how time has been watched before is
that the story is moving forward without
developing any of the characters or
balancing or managing the tension of the
episode
it's kind of hard to explain having the
array to tell us something is a lot less
interesting than it being shown to us in
some way and i feel that we could have
skipped straight to icalgo seeing the
writing on the wall in nen which was the
most
interesting thing in regard to think
about then back into the actual story of
how he's going to continue the mission
adding the other captives back to the
story was completely irrelevant or
if it's not no relevance is communicated
other than
oh you might be interested to know which
no i'm i'm actually not though i want to
know where keela
is what yoobi's doing what pouf is doing
and you're wasting time on this so give
me action now
even watching knuckles thought process
which frankly was moving far too quickly
for me to believe it's actually
happening but then i enjoyed his
realization that one thinks quickly when
they're about to die so i'll let it
stand because it made a point that we
had to wait this long for bravado to
step into the lift is
another episodes ago we were given a
whole lot of information about the
effect of the lift i would be very
surprised
to find that tagashi planned out any of
that it feels more like a panting move
where tagashi realizes he's going to
have to find a way to get
calgo out of trouble and so sends
bravado into the list anyway
let's move on to episode 119 and maybe
i'll have a hat to eat at the end or
some
words to eat or something i don't know
episode 119 and we're setting up for
sheila perf's freedom despite the fact
that morel should have been able to read
the situation just
a little faster i know that the whole
thing is a little more wibbly-wobbly now
and that we have to slow things down
because thought moves faster than speech
and they need to talk things out but i
still get the feeling the scenes with
morel and shia could have been more
economical
meanwhile a little murder boyo became a
super saiyan for the first time i'm not
certain why we got the style of art we
did for it being described to us the um
the strange little uh not strange
they're just i don't know what
i don't know how to describe it like
it's japanese art like ancient art like
not ancient but old
like tapestry art i don't it's old art i
don't know why we got that
but it's nice to see kilwa stepping up
and showing us what he can do even if it
makes a point that the kids are stronger
by far than knuckle and shoot and that
he's likely been hiding his time ability
from gone which i find
really interesting the idea that kilwa
is actually just holding back
because god wants to feel strong is one
that i
will endlessly believe to be true that
is my head cannon you cannot take it
from me
it's mine since kill was able to do the
things he did i'm as intrigued as weepy
there's been such a marked knot strength
in all the combatants so far i find it
fascinating that it's so easy for
kilowatt to step up like that it points
to something we tend to ignore when it
comes to shows like this and that
sidekick ability beyond gone and the
king
or gon and pito we haven't really needed
to see character strength in relative
terms for some time
in fact the last time i recall it
happening was volleyball guy and it he
wasn't really an enemy well
wait there was that other guy that
wanted to win at cards wait hmm
that other guy boom bom
wow this arc is so much weirder than
that and i thought that was weird
we haven't even seen sulky in a long
time and i wonder where the others are
where did the phantom troop go
is layorio a bug now or honestly i think
about that more than i do about bravado
who's i mean let's be honest bravado's a
hitmonchan blastoise lobster fan boy
like
really what what is going on with all of
that poor bro's entire existence is to
highlight
that actually our octobuddy is the most
humane character in the series
other than sushi whoa we're going into
all the memories tonight seeing ikalgo
being so humane is seen as a bad thing
only in the context of
the foolishness shoot and knuckle
engaged in i noticed in this episode
that shoot either died or
lost consciousness too because the
essence de weepy he took disappeared so
maybe he's gonna be
alone in paying for the stupidity of
pride i'm sorry buddy it was the other
dude he did it he didn't save you
anyway back to icalgo it calcu's the
brains it makes sense that he and kilwa
would get along really given the shared
actual
thought that goes into the actions they
take which really isn't something any of
the others do
like the ants everyone but the king
works off of instinct and what we're
seeing here is that
actually they're all super flawed
instinct
don't do it don't use instinct kilowatt
and calgo
understand the stakes of their situation
but when it comes down to it they don't
just think about themselves they think
about how the whole team needs to be
working
as a team it's going to get them both
killed maybe eventually
i just quila chameleon icalgo and morel
are trying to do what needs to be done
for you know the world benefit
gone and the two knuckleheads new band
debuting this summer are failing
miserably seeing icalgo navigate the
situation and the
environment is a great moral compass for
us to know what an ordinary person would
do is always a nice reminder of the
things we have at play here
and what we should expect i did to be
honest get a wave of mild irritation
that we switched over to the icalgo
bravada storyline because i felt like i
didn't get quite as much of the main
story as i wanted before we made that
jump i do understand that it was
narratively necessary though and i was
somewhat charmed by the animatedness of
the cute plan
animation or planimation as we shall now
call it i like when art styles shift
because an art style is designed to
communicate a story
and communicate emotions and what
takashi has done often is prioritize the
story he's trying to tell over whether
or not it looks attractive
and by and large it's worked in my
opinion once i learned to appreciate the
change in style and storyline i found
that it did a pretty good job of holding
on to the tension enough while shifting
the reason for it i stayed largely
engaged and therefore am
quite content with the episode overall
and it is with that contentment that i
leave you because that's it from me
if you enjoyed my rambling meander
through arcs and time and all the weird
noises i make and questioning everything
about the story and its tension-grabbing
abilities click here here
yeah tell people about this
even if it's just in the comments
section
i'll see you next time